welcome to this video playing Zack
Martin from turkey three and a half out
of five is my score against this against
this person and let's see maybe I can
play the Kings Indian attack for a
change uh-huh taking only for that's not
played that often should down should be
quite comfortable for white try to
establish this advanced pawn on e5 going
to cover it with Queen to rook e1 to g4
yeah maybe he wants to play a quick f 6m
possible
yeah if it does not play f6 the whole
operation is a bit strange really but f6
know otherwise i'll play h3 and sent the
night to the rim I don't think that this
is any good Oh surprising so aged 3 or
night everyone now let's make sure that
the nidus is on on h6 yeah it can play
Bishop basic so it's not not a big big
problem I have fos a good square this
isn't Hector visual basics no no what
what now what now Eddie Aikau go with
the night to age for losers FCC six and
back to h6 hmm ok so 93 m just
activating the night and threatening
maybe g5 directly Joe 35 and 95 it just
it just allows me to take that I can
also take age six and play Queen F form
and that's also quite strong by the way
he cannot cover h6 in any way
and also 94 I have six hours of
additional possibility
no that's okay he probably has to play
King a jade
after which i can take age six i can try
to improve further with night h5 maybe
I'm not sure it's night h5 better or 94
h5 looks somewhat more dangerous with
the the g7 threats let's play this first
two to make sure that after up jet I can
take f7 I take it first yeah let's let's
take it first and now think about things
Knight f6 and it's not doing much good
there is no direct wind I think don't
don't see it at least
how to improve him now I can play
various centralizing moose maybe the
Queen isn't that great here early and
maybe then Knight f6 now thats that's
nice taking Queen takes sighs very nice
and here I'll just um be the quicker be
be quicker on the D file yeah that's
less looks like good control I don't I
don't need to mate Emma necessarily just
keeping the huge position of advantages
is good enough nigel is trying to
threaten on h7 on d3 this combined
threats maybe it takes Queen takes I can
do it
yeah various ideas now one of them okay
now we get a forced forced line um no no
I have it all nicely protected one idea
was to sometimes take your play Bishop
b4 to break through but it's not clear
that is working at the moment but now
Bishop c6 is a simple thread between 2x
quindi aid stuff tough to to play play
something in move the Queen areas also
dat nite f7 is also a motif
and I don't really see a movie Bishop c6
as a bit too strong and okay bishops is
67 route 28 mate black resigns now this
this is a very this this is capture
already is a very early concession where
normally white is giving is getting
quite a good game but he should probably
retreat now I really not believe that
Nigeria is particularly great the
computer his stock fish wants to play
Knight c4 yeah it's also not bad at all
he has a hard time to play b5 because of
the long diagonal okay well this is not
bad as well just keeping an etchant here
was really surprised that he allowed to
be pushed back to to the edge of the
board my sis losing lots of time and I
make I make useful moves in the process
8 a-5 it's really leading to big trouble
he should probably play Bishop e7 this
is this is just very nice for white but
nothing nothing decisive I have h4 night
h2g 4 and so on I can concentrate my
pieces on the Kings side for possible
attack in the game after this it is very
very problematic because he know needs
to he needs two yeah go back to h6
basically if we look at this oops
yeah and this is also very problematic I
just um I just took them next nigel is
also a good good continuation that's
that's even a better move that's even
better yeah because now I'm going to
take on on age six and even have this
end with this huge hole on f6 so this is
a total win I mean just like resigns
immediately but ok this was keeping
keeping a very glad yeah now look you
when i think i played this ok keeping
control yeah this is this is falling
falling apart completely yeah black
probably shouldn't take on the form but
the main issue was that this energy for
at the end radium turned out to be a
huge loss of time and at the end of the
night was just flipping back and forth
between all those squares to be taken
with a bad pawn structure at the end ok
thanks for watching